come and see what everyone's talking
about there's only one Jesus was his
messenger bismillah al hamdulillah
Salaam alaikum peace be with you you are
watching the Dean show and we are here
trying to help you develop a better
understanding about Islam which is the
fastest growing way of life in the world
today yet most misunderstood but after
people dig a little bit and they start
to join us here weekly on the D show
they get inspired they get happy and
many even accept this wonderful way of
life that was lived by all the
messengers of God because they all
brought and taught the same message to
acquire peace by submitting your will to
the owner of peace the One God and today
the crucial question many people start
to ask when we provide all the rational
logical evidence that Jesus peace be
upon him was a mighty messenger and in
no way was he divine with God in no way
did he call people to worship Him people
ask well then what was he a liar a
lunatic or was he Lord he had to be one
of them well we're going to be
addressing this very important question
when we come back we'll be answering
with dr. Gerald Dirk's as a former
Christian preacher teacher Deacon who
finished from the prestigious Harvard
University with the divinity degree
we'll be right back with more here on
the Dean show la is only one
Muhammad is His Messenger a la la la
ha there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger oh no I did that maybe it
maybe it's just to break the ice please
be with you assalamu alaikum and peace
upon you brother thank you for joining
us here again on the Dean show my
pleasure we are going to get straight
into the topic as time is short and we
want to for those who want to know a
little bit more about you they can go to
the den show com you have your own
private section we've done several shows
with you in the past you have your
biography there so people can read and
learn about who you were what you've
done but today the crucial question is
many people are asking when we provide
all the evidence from the Bible from the
Koran the verbatim word of God that
Jesus and no Muslim is a Muslim unless
he believes in Jesus he was indeed a
mighty messengers of God who call people
to the same message worship to create or
not his creation then people ask well
then what was he was he a liar was he a
lunatic crazy if not then he had to be
Lord what do we have to say well you
left off the fourth choice which is none
of the above none of the above none of
the above and as Muslims that's
certainly our answer he wasn't a liar he
was on a lunatic and now he wasn't our
Lord if by any stretch of the
imagination you mean to imply divinity
my master teacher couldn't Lord mean
that also uh well they're not implying
that but can a lord be it like you know
like you have like today you know have
Lord judges are car Lords how was it
according out whether whether is with a
capital L or lowercase L yeah in terms
of a master or a teacher certainly we
Muslims would have no objection no
objection is being referred to that way
but as a Divine Son of God now they
don't know that that's where we would
draw the line so what do we do now and
well you know I think we point out that
we certainly respect Jesus we accept him
as one of the messengers of God bringing
revelation from God to us but we do not
accept him as
God or being divine himself now some
people will go and look at the Bible now
I want to make a no correct me you're
our teacher here you're a Bible scholar
you know this book quite well very well
you spent years and years and years and
you got a master's davitt in a divinity
in it we as Muslims once have
consciously chosen to submit to the One
God we believe that there is part of
some of God's Word in the Bible but
there's also the word of prophets his
stories and people we don't even know
who are right is that true right i mean
you know many of the books of the bible
we're not i'm asleep written as far as
we know and sure we we believe that
there's probably a lot of divine
revelation be found in the Bible yeah
but there's probably also some other
things as well that we can't attribute
to God correct okay but now to entertain
even some of these verses that people
will bring because I think that in any
court of law if you can't produce the
witness the case is thrown out but we're
still entertaining this so some people
will say you know what and we've done a
show on this in the past they can go to
the Dean show calm it's called is Jesus
God and you clearly you shone through
history the early Christian sects and
this is another myth that many people
try to say no all the Christians at that
time believed it this is also a myth
absolutely you know that we know there
were Jewish Christian groups that
flourished including the Church of
Jerusalem under James the righteous
these were Jewish Christian groups they
denied the divinity of Jesus the mb a--
nights would be another one the
Nazarenes not to be confused with the
modern denomination of the same name the
elca sites you know these were groups
that basically denied the divinity of
Jesus now in the past show the one I
mentioned is Jesus God we went over some
of the common arguments or versus people
who views and you basically you explain
them in their context and show that no
these are more like kind of like that
wasn't the core shot Rorschach test or
shot tell ya where it's nothing explicit
it's something that you can deduce
whatever you wanted to do yeah you
project onto it your own from your own
self yeah but now there's a few that we
didn't cover so one will mention like
let's say that you know they took up
stones
ones in the Bible to stone him because
he was claiming he was God what do you
have to say about this well let's look
at the actual passes yeah you know and
let's look at it in context and what
you're referring to us from the tenth
chapter of John yeah the Jews took up
stones against took up stones again to
stone him this is john chapter 10 verses
31 through 36 jesus replied i have shown
you many good works from the father for
which of these are you going to stone me
the jews answered it is not for a good
work that we are going to stone you but
for blasphemy because you though only a
human being are making yourself god
jesus answered is it not written in your
law I said you are God's if those to
whom the words of God came are called
gods and the scripture cannot be
annulled can you say that the one whom
the father has sanctified and sent into
the world as blaspheming because I said
I am God son that's John chapter 10
verses 31 through 36 now if you're going
to take that passage as a statement that
Jesus is claiming divinity you're making
a number of assumptions yes and let's
just delineate what those assumptions
are first of all you're assuming that
John or whoever wrote the Gospel of John
is recording the passage accurately
that's the first assumption secondly
you're assuming that Jesus actually said
this that's the second assumption and in
fact there are some reasons to doubt
that Jesus actually said this so for
example when he says in this quotation I
said you are God's he's quoting here
from the Old Testament but what's
fascinating is he's quoting from the
Greek Septuagint yes he's not quoting
from the Hebrew masoretic text he's
quoting from the Greek because the words
are identical to the Greek Septuagint
not to the Hebrew
now why would jesus peace be upon him in
Palestine in the first century be
quoting from the Greek Old Testament and
said it from the Hebrew this raises real
questions yeah secondly according to the
statement as we have it jesus answered
is it not written in your law I said you
are gods well that reference to your law
the torah but the Torah is Genesis
Exodus Leviticus numbers and Deuteronomy
just the fart first five this is the
first five that's the door yeah and then
the second division of Hebrew Scriptures
the nova game and the third divisions
the catch a team this quotation it
actually comes from the 82nd chapter of
Psalms verse 6 through seven that's not
part of the tour and that's part of the
cat devine now from all accounts Jesus
was a very learned scholar of Hebrew
Scripture yes and for him to make a
claim that something's coming from the
Torah but in fact it's coming from
Psalms is a little hard to understand
how that sort of mistake could be made
so again that's the second reason we
might well question whether Jesus
actually even said these words but the
second thing we need to consider all
together as does the statement mean
Jesus is God well let's look at what he
said is it not written in your law I
said you are God's if those to them the
words of God came were called gods and
the scripture cannot be at all can you
say that the one whom the father is
sanctified in sentence of the world is
blaspheming because I said I am God son
he's contrasting i am god son but you're
called gods well if you're saying the
latter means divinity godson then so
does the former in other words
everybody's got ya so i think we have to
look at the context on the context of
what Jesus is actually saying certainly
from my reading of it
there's no statement of divinity being
played and many others not just yours
many others would also line up in
conjunction with what years yeah again
that's what you're saying before when we
start looking at some of this stuff it's
like looking at a Rorschach inkblot
people are going to project onto it from
them on their own cell was their desire
is wanting sure when they want to see
okay we're gonna take a break and right
back with more with dr. Gerald Dirk's
here on the deed show no speech is
better than to do that was call people
to Allah and to do there were no
speeches better no nothing is better
than that is it true that if one person
I'm the Allah giving you an ability to
guide someone for the lost permission
the creator's permission that was better
than everything in this world but in the
whole world and everything that's in it
in another narration it's better than
the best of wealth but if we really felt
that Eddie would we not be giving out
getting down and this is something that
we encourage all the msas all the dowel
organizations the mustards to get this
we want to prep more we give these to
the non melissa's for free for free for
free we want our brothers age
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if allies by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone I am
not afraid to stand alone if allies by
my side I am not afraid to stand alone I
am not afraid to stand alone if allies
by my side I am not afraid to stay
back here on the Dean show with dr.
Gerald Dirk's and we're answering the
question Jesus peace be upon him who no
Muslim is a Muslim unless he believes in
Jesus we believe in the miracles that he
did that he gave life to the dead with
God's permission that He healed the sick
that he was indeed a mighty messenger of
god but nowhere in the Bible or any
Scripture that Jesus ever claimed that
he was divine that he was a literal Son
of God and you also at many of other
shows proved historically that many of
the Christian sects at that time there
was an adoption asteri he was
subordinate to God so the evidence is
there that proves that they can go to
the Dean show calm and look under dr.
gero certain section is jesus god
amongst of the topics that we did now
continuing on there are also prophecies
that people tried to link from the Old
Testament and the one we want to cover
something in Isaiah and they'll try to
link it back to the New Testament and
say look look look look here the
prophecy came fulfilled and he's got you
have a specific prophecy of the one in
Isaiah talking about the kingdom he'll
be on his shoulder okay yeah this is the
ninth chapter of Isaiah ja verse 6 for a
child has been born for us a sudden
given to us authority rests upon his
shoulders and he is named wonderful
counselor mighty God everlasting father
Prince of Peace sighs alien that's the
one that's the one okay and people want
to say well this is Jesus and I say look
at that mighty God well look at the next
phrase everlasting father everlasting
father yeah now wait a minute you can't
pick and choose here in this verse it's
not a buffet now no he'll you take
everything that's there wonderful
counselor mighty God everlasting father
so we tell them what the one guy wow you
know unless somehow Trinitarians are
going to want to claim that Jesus is the
father and not the Sun then you can't
really make this piece of Scripture
apply to Jesus and this is an hour past
show you says something about this being
a heretical statement
saying that Jesus was the father or
something in that text where we're to
believe that Jesus is God that he's
actually God giving and not separate in
a Trinity a few oh Jesus is God period
period yes without without recognizing
that Jesus is also human yes yeah that
that's officially heresy and that's
where national Christianity traditional
Christian oh yeah yeah there were three
basic positions on the nature of Jesus
that were fought about theologically the
first few centuries one was Jesus is God
period yeah the other is Jesus is both
God and man simultaneously that's
basically the official position of
traditional Christianity and the third
position is Jesus man although a man who
was selected as a recipient of God's
revelation and stood in a special
relationship to God yeah so how do you
close off this now this is PIP this is
this argument is done the one you just
covered in Isaiah this is talking about
if you look at and you add those extra
words at the end this is not talking
about Jesus well I'm not adding extra
words this has been the verse yeah yeah
everlasting father he is named
everlasting father so this cancels out
now well it certainly cancels out any
Trinitarian possibility if you're saying
that Jesus is the father okay I mean
because the Trinitarian concept disease
the sub this is easy to see it's a
blatant contradiction again we covered
this before about I am another one again
now that's brought up that before
Abraham was I am we got to say about
this well again let's look at the actual
verse yeah jesus said to them very truly
I tell you before Abraham was I am so
they picked up stones to throw it in but
Jesus hid himself and went out of the
temple John 8 verse 58 now number of
assumptions that are being made and we
need to highlight what those assumptions
are by those who are saying is somehow
shows that Jesus is God an assumption
that some Christians are making here
anyway is that when this verse
I am before Abraham was I am it's
referring back to Exodus 3 verse 14 God
said to Moses I am Who I am yeah and he
further said the shall you say to the
Israelites I am has sent me to you well
again we're assuming that that goes back
there we don't know that that's an
assumption you know the I am and Exodus
is in Hebrew the IM in John is Greek we
do not know that a literal translation
was made from what Jesus would have
spoken which was Aramaic to the greek
plus you know there are a lot of Bible
scholars who say you know the IM
translation and exodus is not quite
accurate you know it sort of gets the
gist but might be more accurate to say
something on the order of i bring him
the being or something on that order
there's about three or four different
technical variations of how that phrase
could be translating again this is
nothing explicit this is nothing
straightforward God doesn't not beat
around the bush and have you like you
know try to figure it out you know give
you like hints here and there no no no
and you know some people would argue
about look if Jesus was before Abraham
all what else could he be yeah besides
God but again you're making assumptions
and one of the assumptions that you're
making is this there is no such thing as
the pre-existence of souls yeah and in
point of fact you know there are many
Muslims who believe that there was
pre-existence of souls for all mankind
yeah and they often refer to a verse
from the Quran when your Lord brings
offspring from out of the loins of the
children of Adam he makes them first
bear witness about themselves by asking
them am I not your Lord Quran 7 verse
they need to sew pre-existence of souls
yeah is how that verse is being read by
many people and we have a following
hadith aisha narrated the Prophet
Mohammed said souls before they became
United with bodies were like assembled
armies and afterwards they were
dispersed and sent into the bodies of
mankatha that's from the mishkat and
from the must not of even handle we have
another hadith which perhaps we can get
to in a moment I tell it before you get
to that now we have a no go ahead finish
this we have a few more ok anas bin
malik said that the Prophet said it will
be said to a man from the people of the
fire on the Day of Resurrection if you
owned all that is on the earth when you
pay it as ransom he will reply yes God
will say I ordered you with what is less
than that when you were still in Adams
loins that is associate done with me and
I with Herrera narrated the Prophet said
when God created Adam he wiped items
back and every person that he will
create from him until the Day of
Resurrection fell out from his back so
we have this pre-existence of souls yeah
so for Jesus to say before Abraham was I
am you know could well be pre-existence
of salt absolutely and again God
Almighty is not the author of confusion
he's not trying to confuse it when God
Almighty says worship me alone right he
would have said Trinity he would have
said crucifixion I'm dying but none of
this is there it's clear worship the One
God the same guy that Jesus worship
Moses Abraham the last and final mention
your problem on peace be upon him him
alone and not his creation that's always
been the same message yes tell us now a
few more points before we cut to a break
you know we cover these in the other
show and people can see it the topic is
Jesus God you covered it but some people
just briefly touch upon this to people
that didn't see this and maybe they
might know how to get a chance to go to
the website for beginning was the word
the word was the god no no that John 11
they mentioned this this is a big one
for the beginning was the word the Word
was with God that God became flesh in
the beginning was the word yes and the
Word was with God the God the Word was
with God yes but not the Word was God
no the Word was with with God yes it
just goes back to what you were just
saying wasn't it and and this is seems
like duality not Trinity yeah at this
point I mean if you're going to take the
word or the logos yeah as being a divine
first of all you have to deal with that
with stay in it but yeah we still
haven't gotten to the Holy Spirit yeah
of Trinitarian Christianity yeah and
although Christianity didn't get to the
Holy Spirit and too well after the
Council of Nicaea yeah and 325 Council
of Nicaea basically talked about the
nature of Jesus didn't formulate much of
anything about the Holy Spirit and we're
going to take a break and we right back
with more with dr. Joe Dirk's here on
the details he is the main teen coming
to the truth requires two things that
requires deep thinking that you've
already done but it requires another
step and that's courage if you have the
truth but you don't have courage you
won't stand up for the truth and that's
as good as standing up for falsehood I
would say this thing that you're just
told me it's not in the scripture and
they would say a marginal note added by
scribe yeah okay we know that and I'd be
thinking if you know this is not the
Bible why are you preaching it as if
it's gospel truth that's from
go
I started out actually in high school I
was a born again Christian I accepted
Christ as my Lord and Savior as we used
to say and I became very committed as an
evangelical Christian and I went off to
moody bible institute for college
because a fundamentalist Bible College
after that I went to Wheaton College
which is a liberal arts college if it's
Billy Graham's alma mater it's in heaven
Jellicle school so I had very solid
evangelical Christian commitments and
eventually I got a seminary degree and I
was a pastor of a Baptist Church for a
year but gradually for a large number of
reasons I started to question some of
the assumptions that I had about the
faith for a long time I thought that the
Bible was inspired and inerrant that
there were no mistakes in the pliable
but as I engaged in historical research
on the Bible as I was getting my PhD in
New Testament studies at Princeton
Theological Seminary I started finding
mistakes in the Bible and this this cut
away at my assumptions that the Bible
was an errand and then I started
questioning other parts of my faith is
Jesus really divine is a really a
Trinity back here in a Dean show with
dr. Gerald Dirk's the key question Jesus
peace be upon him liar lunatic or Lord
none of the above asma stata he's no way
indeed not a liar he is not a lunatic
and Lord if you meant what we said
earlier a teacher like all the
messengers of God they would teaching
people how to worship God then we agree
but if you say Lord divine not at all
exactly now tell us for God so loved the
world that He sent His only begotten Son
that whoever believeth in him shall have
eternal life that preaches up on a
podium they're saying look look look and
they're given this verse what do you
have to say well first of all begotten
does not appear in all versions no some
manuscripts delete the door begotten
entirely I think we have to look
contextually you know throughout the
Bible we see all sorts of people being
referred to as set of God
or child of God yeah you know David to
refer to as son of God ephriam some of
Joseph peace be upon it referred to as a
child of God etc well we have numerous
people throughout the Old Testament read
referred to as son of God the Israelite
people as a whole referred to as the
children of God basically when you said
someone was the son of God or the child
of God within the context the first
century Palestine you're basically
saying there is a very pious and
righteous man mm-hmm and that's all you
were saying that's it yeah that's in the
context yeah historically I think now
psychologically if we look at this from
another totally different perspective
people attach themselves to to Jesus and
we love him yes and no Muslim as i said
earlier muslim unless he believes in
Jesus but people just wanting so much to
believe this they've been taught this
this has been instilled in them and they
develop you know this relationship they
feel with Jesus and now they're deducing
this versa no matter if we go on for
another two hours or a day and we'll
hopefully for the sincere person by now
he's got it but the other person just
holding on so tight to this
psychologically is there you know from
another perspective why do you think
people do this well yeah I want one
thing that happens is how the Bible is
translated yeah you know if you look in
the most versions of the Bible you look
in the New Testament if it's referring
to Jesus the Son of God like in the
verse that we quoted earlier you know
they put a capital S on sun that capital
last isn't in the Greek yeah you know
that's something the translators
sticking in to make sure you interpret
the passage a certain way that's not
actually in the Bible you know the Greek
doesn't have capital lowercase
distinctions yeah what I'm thinking look
at this you know when you you form God
into your mind and your life around that
now you've gotten comfortable you're
making your own way you're doing your
own thing and this now you got the JC go
cart you get to throw everything on his
back which now you know
it alleviates some of maybe the the set
the the responsibility that you're
supposed to have you know and you don't
want to change your ways I'm not going
to get into nobody's heart but you can
see like somehow where you know this is
convenient now I could do my old thing
you know God I made him into my mind how
I feel that he should be me now I'm
stuck on it can this be possibly
something that's going on well yeah and
there's there's certainly that there's
also the aspect that you know there's a
sense of assurance assurance that's it
that Trinitarian Christianity offers you
know if you believe in Jesus is the Son
of God and accept the sacrifice he
allegedly made for you on the cross then
you are assured of salvation yes doesn't
matter what else yeah you know you've
got it me this is your get out of hell
card free yeah to use it a paraphrase
for monopoly a slump doesn't offer that
level of assurance no you know because
Islam says look you have to watch how
you live your life mm-hmm you have to
believe correctly that there's only one
God one God and worship that one God but
you have to live your life correctly yes
you cannot sin against God you cannot
sin against your fellow man yes you know
you have to live correctly this is all
going to fit onto a scale on the day of
judgment now fortunately for all of us
God's mercy is also going to enter into
that equation otherwise would be a lot
of us in a lot of very bad shape but
there is still this issue of
accountability for one's life that's
there in the slum definitely so the
question can we say that it's been
answered liar lunatic or Lord none of
the above none of the above yeah but
what mighty messenger of god mighty
messenger of god etc you'd mentioned
before you know teacher master Messiah
let me complete my thought and I'll get
back to Messiah teacher master etc it's
interesting to see what that word
actually is
text you know it's basically rabbi rabbi
teacher rabbi yeah you know Jesus being
referred to as rabbi yeah now in terms
of Messiah SIA which means Christ also
well Christ is the greek greek version
of the hebrew word Messiah yeah or which
we say Messiah so we believe he was the
Messiah yeah of course Quran tells us
he's the Christ the Word of God he's a
word of God but in the Word of God in
the sense that we're told in the Quran
that and the miraculous creation of the
virgin birth God says be and it is does
this is created in the and the loom of
Mary yes we're out of time and people if
they want to invite you to do a lecture
to you know how can they get a hold of
you they can contact me at dirks online
books calm thank you once again for
being with us Hannah my pleasure brother
I got Almighty a lot of woods and we got
to answer another very very important
question today it was was Jesus peace be
upon him liar lunatic or Lord and it's
none of the above he was indeed a mighty
messenger of god who came with the same
message that all the messengers of God
taught to worship the One God the one
create tour and not what he created be
thankful to him be grateful to him and
do all the good proved by action that
you love God because talk is cheap and
you're going to be held accountable
because there's a day of judgment and if
you do good you strive for good you'll
have paradise you'll get God's grace and
God's mercy but you got to prove it
through actions you got to walk the walk
talk the talk and continue to tune in
every week here to the Dean show to
learn more we'll see you next time God
willing peace be unto you is the main
teen one of the beautiful things about
our religion of Islam is the emphasis on
direct ritual and prayer thing
directly there is no intermediary the
lights will go on after the party and
the party will end it's very simple and
very clear there are no superstitious
rituals no strange incantations and time
is running out we might not make it to
tomorrow and this is something that we
need to think about no speech is better
than to do that would call people to
Allah and to do there were no speech is
better no nothing is better than that is
it true that if one person I'm the Allah
giving you an ability to guide someone
for the lost permission the creator's
permission that was better than
everything in this world but in the
whole world and everything that's in it
in another narration it's better than
the best of wealth but if we really felt
that Eddie would we not be giving out
giving down and this is something that
we encourage all the msas all the dowel
organizations the mustards forget this
we want to print more we give these to
the Nautilus's for free for free for
free we want our brothers age it's cold
ain't lay everybody sleeping I arise and
ask a lot of thinking me omar you see
all are you know all the sins i do i
turn to you to figure my sing tomorrow
I'm sinful slave yo my love
runs away Oleg I me